le mode mais c'est souvent le retour du
beau temps c'est l'occasion de faire des
sorties en extérieur je vais en profiter
j'ai sorti mon petit vélo l'idée c'est
de vous faire découvrir un peu les
environs on part que tv 78 on va faire
un petit tour va voir jusqu'où ce
happening et essayer de découvrir des
beaux paysages du département c'est
parti
mais
partant de guyancourt j'ai choisi une
boucle qui passe par le parc national de
la vallée de chevreuse dampierre en
yvelines connu pour son château jusqu'à
la destination finale la bt votre cerner
très de rambo
[Musique]
5 minutes que je suis parti pour
l'instant on reste dans la ville bien
sûr mais toujours sur des pistes
cyclables donc c'est plutôt sécurisant
et il fait déjà chaud donc je me demande
si d'ici quelques minutes je vais pas
enlever mon cou
[Musique]
pour choisir le trajet me guider j'ai
utilisé une application mobile on rentre
une destination elles ne trouvent une
voie adaptée on peut choisir d'avoir un
chemin direct sécurisé touristique ou
bien équilibrée et le petit bonus pour
l'événement du mais à vélo on a un
classement départemental selon ces
kilomètres parcourus dans le monde
[Musique]
je fais une petite pause ici parce que
c'est vraiment frappant l'espace de les
500 m 2 minutes on est passé de la ville
à la campagne là il ment c'est tendu
devant moi donc c'est plutôt agréable
[Musique]
pour vient de faire une grosse descente
donc forcément après tout descente faut
bien remonté c'est parti on sait on à
baisser la vitesse et on a le temps de
toute façon
[Musique]
pour vous
là
[Musique]
dans la descente que j'aime faire elle
est connue par les cyclistes du coin
c'est la descente des dix sept tournant
là j'arrive à dampierre en yves hinse a
à peu près la moitié de mon trajet aller
donc on va voir ce qu'on peut faire
pendant les 7 km qui nous reste
[Musique]
pour
bon voilà je suis arrivé à la bd vous
cernez c'est la moitié de notre trajet
je vous fais pas de petite visite parce
qu'il est en rénovation en ce moment
nous ça nous fait en tout cas la moitié
du trajet on a 20 km ce qui fait qu'avec
le retour cela fera 40 km pour le nez à
vélo de l'équipe des yvelines pour faire
un petit bilan de cette allée alors au
début dans les communes y avait des voix
ou des pistes cyclables à chaque fois
donc c'était plutôt sécurisant ensuite
quand on arrive en ruralité bien sûr
nice ont pu mais on est quand même pas
mal à distance avec les voitures le
petit bémol peut-être ces quelques
camions que j'ai croisés quand ils nous
dépasse à haute vitesse c'est pas
toujours très rassurant mais ça fait
partie du jeu faut être prudent donc
voilà on va y retourner tranquillement
mais on va prendre notre temps puisque
l'important c'est pas d'aller vite c'est
de voir de beaux paysages c'est de se
faire plaisir aussi
[Musique]
souvenez-vous à l'aller je suis passé
par la mythique code des dix sept
tournant en descente au retour je dois
donc affronter son équivalent du côté du
mesnil-saint-denis ce ne sont pas les 17
mai les sept tournois
[Musique]
vous
bon je suis à mi chemin du retour donc
j'en profite pour faire une petite pause
pour admirer un peu le paysage et après
on va repartir pour les dix derniers
kilomètres
[Musique]
pour finir ma boucle est rentré à
guyancourt mon chemin n'a conduit à
travers la verrière et rap c'est
plusieurs bains et moins adaptés aux
vélos que ma première partie de route et
bien sûr pour terminer toute épopée il
fallait forcément une petite averse
heureusement j'étais presque arrivé
voilà donc je suis bien revenu au point
de départ donc au total ça fait quarante
kilomètres à rythme léger l'important
quand on se lance de toute façon c'est
de choisir un trajet selon sa forme et
bien sûr les lieux qu'on souhaite
explorer il me reste plus qu'à vous
souhaiter bon courage pour ce mois de
mai à vélo et à bientôt
[Musique]